heck yeah well maybe you have some time
off this week and are looking for
something to do
well 30 minutes outside of town in good
springs nevada
you'll find adrenaline mountain a
one-stop shop for thrills
a place to release some stress escape to
the outdoors
even get married i'm there
welcome to adrenaline mountain
[Applause]
hit it mitch
[Music]
hey eric how's it going hey how are you
dude what what was that vehicle i was
just in man
that's called a hemet a heavy expanded
expandable mobile tactical truck this is
insane up here how would you describe
adrenaline mountain
so this is like a adrenaline amusement
park i mean we have
multiple attractions here we have some
very cool stuff
uh definitely on the edge definitely
adrenaline
uh adrenaline pumping but also
definitely safe
so what are some of the other
attractions that you guys have here i
could tell you
but i'd rather show you let's do it
let's do it all right eric you got a big
excavator and a car behind us what are
we doing oh we're going to do a little
car crushing
anyone can get in that thing anyone can
get in that thing even you
i can do it yep all right sam hold on
let's do it i'm getting into him oh here
we go i'm going to start smashing you
guys ready for me to smash here we go
all day long who wants to see it jc
smash i do
you feel this thing up and uh jc smash
there we go at one point so went to a
showroom
they financed their life savings to get
this car and now we're smashing it on
las vegas now
i love it thank you sam all right jc
we're going to take you out onto our 400
acre property
we're going to show you the custom
off-road trails that we cut
and we're going to show you some
glamping spots that we're working on
we're going to be offering glamping in
the future this is perfect
escape the city let's do it visors down
eric and uh
let's hit it brother here we go
these trails are amazing
this is paradise in front of me what are
you looking at they were on actually on
top of yellow pine mine tailing
so yellow pine mine was the big biggest
mine in the area
back in the 30s and this is one of our
glamping spots
this is perfect i could spend weeks up
here it's been quite the day out here
eric what are some of the other things
that
i didn't get to see so some of the
things we didn't get to we have axe
throwing
we have archery we have drive a monster
truck
you didn't get a chance to do you'll
have to do that next time you come up
next time i'm coming back another time
and you also have this is the shooting
range and so whether you're a beginner
or an expert you can come up here and
shoot some guns lots of first-time
shooters that we get
we have over 80 guns for guests to
choose from and uh
we got a little demonstration for you
today okay so we have the firing line i
think lance we need to focus on the
firing line over there no lance
actually let's focus on that white car
over there the white car with a little
dot on it that's the one
all right send it
[Music]
oh
is adrenaline mountain wow oh my gosh
now that's why you started a monday heck
yeah rocky we're going we're gonna go
blow up a car
i'm here i'm ready i'm ready for more
information go to adrenaline
mountain.com it's so much fun up there
jason